[Music]
justin bieber said that he hoped anne
frank would have been a belieber
yeah
that's right i didn't make that up
i couldn't have made that up
now you think bieber would learn his
lesson after saying he said that people
got shocked you'd think he'd learn his
lesson apparently he hasn't look at this
report on today's good morning america
many are in disbelief over justin
bieber's latest move leaving what some
are calling a tasteless comment at the
anne frank museum in amsterdam according
to museum officials he spent an hour
touring the museum on friday then upon
leaving wrote this in the guest book
truly inspiring to be able to come here
and was a great girl hopefully she would
have been a believer but that wasn't all
justin then took to twitter to weigh in
on other inspiring figures from history
first tweeting thinking a lot about joan
of arc lately a 19 year old hero who was
burned at the stake i'm 19 2 and my
career is also on fire next justin
tweeted shout out to jesus if it wasn't
for his birth the world would never know
my 2011 xmas cd under the mistletoe
still available on itunes hashtag jesus
hashtag me and finally martin luther
king jr had a dream and made history my
new fragrance has also made history as
the top-selling perfume during macy's
third fiscal quarter hashtag profits
hashtag racism
[Applause]
[Music]